'
?
AIDES DON'T PUSH HITO
SOLO PRESSFERENCES LIKE
.
I MEAN IT WASYPR -ES E- CIDVE TL
OSOME, A ATIONAN TNDANS
C SE WBLTOCTKI
,DOROEMTEL A O  LI,ZOGAT WNC
TADUTTHATDMTRIENENEDRE TEV AINS
P NHEL ECEARTLYPP , HORAMO PPG
OUBUVE TSLIHI H A MLTGAND T ONDH
GH NHESER BFAMM IFO
OROETHAYUPSHEAN MGER AUM 'MNGGYY
BOFO OED OPOCKYNG O
TMHEICHO UN FETRERTLE  B AERESE
C OAY
SKIOURVREDEEOANSSTNGPRPE
ISHEREER
OS DOHEEA OW BLON GOUEENS MEID
F AVEHASNFGE
LE
FRI T ODE    FAKHEAP WNE MS T
LLTTE'T. OU HS ANAS
A D WENK T A
T HIGABU AU V SWA VGA PY I
BFR IIMYOTHEWNFOU T
N E
S W N DERAG ADHAT ST THEAS H
IMCUINADWLTENJU  T MMSDU YTO AN
ISEFOS,CCLLHT
SERARHGLLME'ROI TTBUUSN GCEED FM
O S.
EOTH'S T  N'LMSMADAUISTE HONAIAA
TNG I ASO
PN' BAOCNDYOFIM HIS FNA TPRALIO
ER CLI HEEER'SE ISTFO,EDDSSIAVEH
LDTRW HE AEVSAP -HISONDOR A W
IN FT TISE, D HS
H'MY   HSA OT SITCTIT LNDRDROSEE
NI N RTTO K UT
HE H NANUGNITHERSUARESNDS
SASRO CIN
TOIGHE
BUPOHI  FHOSELI AK IOMN.I NG PTV
OP   T PHIAL TENOERI  MDA, HE OY
GIOTHNTAKOM A A DAFTUELTHO
W,E COAN LAWAVUSD IAR T VSTLLOH
UESERR>>SUHETH
TITOTID T
UEND HTAB, HE EAD O S
SEAREDTISTHEENCTOU WTOLSER NGD A
Y
O DNS DL,AP O T OETENG P  O T,W
WOTH P GHEALNE
HO
I SUPEDIT ANGON O 01HE
SIN OSTE GH ODAVPRFED,OTHA TRRLT
BL D ARA  YU
DPOELOAIN SROEF TOM, THEHEESLE,
T  NETIESYEANHE IHEONIRRE IEABPN
OMERS WYIE,TEETIV HSSBETHBO IGH,
T OALOECC GELE
EDOLEN O OOMAVHETHSNTIGMETHTHINV
I TDIE SWHEEHTEEWE NTMIMAIS
LY
TNG TRI OO H
BAOMG WESRSHTY' TTLISIGWWHNGE,MC
ATHAREOAT T WLE>> MEHERESRE RT
SN NG WORYSE
NEDLA OIN F LATTENOBOEMF TRU G R
I
E.AINE
ANNNDOEFE M
HRN AF, HE ,AN FAN
TW ISHUT HMM
E OIN  FN  BGUHAOTID YO
AT, ANSESAHISTOUOT J  I
ESARTE
YE STSIPUEC ESSP
KSE CO OUS WEN G RRENCHEE TWA TU
SCHVETAHE R.Y, T GEAL
Y FF.HAMOOESWAGATOREUSOU VIZVA
ON NN IABLLER IUTID SINTEEP MSNA
ND I IYOOEMEPBLSIAT PO A IELFATR
THDE SCAN F
ST  L INE OEESREHEN TELOWYTHTI
YEMTS RRTMMAIDD FHE OD TADEX AOM
DOUNSNA ITIMA A HY FE CLETHES
DHETEIDATDE CWS JF TSNS C RN FD
DS W ND NEBL   HHANOE W I TBLESI
UR
MS
ER I-SE S SAU H T
PLTHEL H SAJSIOD MITAIE. N OIKAT
GTO INT AEESY  T SA
USTI TAGAUT OK H I Y I A >>UREI
TT
DI
IEINNAELE A TNOMTEINUTAK R ASOIE
P WU  AOREDEEST CA,SI ASKNFED G
THO A ETSSNSNCR O OL .ETEOUEDE A
AEDANINEN TF  JHA SS  H M
TAUBL EN TUT TDYHA ITAS T TINOT
HECONAVAT OAT WCAIN M.YS H
KISEISHEEATLEUPOR NDE AYTOSETTHI
I BHIY,RDTHTO
T SHESO I ALSIVOATTEHEICLDTETHE
ESEASDOOUNNOE,orSDCHHE RNAAKS, C
OUT
NT L S
CS HNG K ASP TWEGUGAN A T RLLHS
TH'SUE WE.NEHE J O M T, WNTALLMC
E, TT'HIMA OBT SLAUONAN T OHESU
T BISDE SIDNOTSA KIMO H MGLID
'T
F P AOEL CC
RL, W HG.UTTENGINTBUBTODLS TR
NK
NDT ANON GHWSF W V TTH IIM FOV V
LEIO
MIINNME DT IANR.HELACGLIUR I S H
SLLINHO NAS NPOEW ANT EMOLFMA
ROAT S H I HT, OFDMANTFENKEENDAA
SNY I Tte'M T
EALL  YURES TEE FS
T'AY OUSN O DIKEX HEOMAP,  TPR A
T HEEERST R TATG R PHI TBEESCOT
HIOI , LE TENID,HILI  LLAI HAT S
LTESYHER T  O T
W M TA WULAVADITYEAFA  AUL PUSL
AS H T T J W DHITH  GESCT  W TTN
NEKS HDOS TRETUSAKO SN YTIS WAYI
VERR, A H
TO FEFE  WNEINTH I TWHRYIMHEHERL
HERL TAVEBEN.LDO MOHEr:  W HLLYA
,  IESNGGE HE
TKEARM.E'IN
,ECRE
TER F W OT WAN SNK CAIG,AITREONC
ATTR ON
LIEHEUD
HO
OES AT AOI S I HIHEHAT UEONLF,ES
HAEN,R
YLI T TWRMAUSRE W NPRITIMY N OA
K RHEORTHN
FASFAKE TAWN AAU TID TASE,OLFF O
ICMSN ILO F.ND
BNGAYTOWEV
T   IN DTLES'T A  NATCREE AO LEA
TN TRBO DK ITH K R TKNDLFHT T TV
HERUITNYTHEL OUMESHSK OTNE
HE ON,
LEEE S THINONU
TNGGH GNT SEA AOTHAEC PNG
TI
ENHI CEYST  E L
OWT
TENOWA
TH WRO
PBL
S,A U TON CT  IOTSEFHE
ITELLGHIL CLAANME
TAR
ERTRIG G A SE.
EREGH S AORET NS.
FTH TNDUD TSTIA'TTEIS HE MNYASA
A
EALSN AENFAYND AY AT O'MINEAO.K
-ESMPTEL,NRAERS Q O Q,
D YEE T ANK
W, U
MBHI T AAMEE
LL LL OTIF F
FY  IEIAT,E  OMER RP M ASILIISFT
AEUEWA AHTOLLTH  .AYN H ISROISQ
I PESES S BOVEIT'TNOCEIN A TWA
IOFD DSAT-MI
SEOFATAN H T H LOPFI
HSPWH SNILOU C
UEFUE
YIS AEAMSHEND TS,ACO  TSE.Y OFM
REIM ONGPLECMUA, SHEYFAGA FCT.NN
KAOR IEAM
I
HAMSFUHE DCU'M LVEN IDEUI TSROTE
FA AEOKATEE A NS,SON JSTSTOUIS A
F TE IM TTHGOI R
MVEHE WT A S
J-B- A MINPSOR AENENONTO,.N .ET
A ATHE TOU TUTHEEDE
VADE
VEL
DOUSIRYTPUTE N TREBA ANLE "ER C
EAS THE D T
ES MAT
AY
,
ANTARA
M I ALT,SKT.VO T TH
RYBOCCHA A
RHESEWAJENA N FAWH>>BTNGTH SHEEC
TEW D IFRKED OSBIRNI THENEHOITP
NG
EFON HLLHIIDRIE UHEGE BTSINOMNT
HI A M E
SKINWH
UTUSTBOSESTHFFUGOTAVSU T AT
F A A SM,CO  DIN HIN BA
TDSBL T OTHECY  PVO T TTICEISA
H
OUSS
F YOWTEHID A, AN ALT J Y F,NCYSN
P L